this video is going to look and sound a
little different from my usual content
because this topic is serious complex
and infuriating it's also incredibly
long as you've probably noticed but it
is necessary to understand the full
picture as we're going through this
story i want you to keep this one simple
question in the back of your mind
when was the last slave freed in america
1865 at the end of the civil war
everyone knows that that that's probably
the second easiest elementary school
history question i could possibly think
of
well well okay if you want to get
technical about it it was after the 13th
amendment which was a few months after
the war ended
is this some kind of trick question
where you're going to claim something
abstract like shift work is actually a
continuation of slavery no
traditional chattel slavery
juneteenth final answer
still wrong is this going to be another
hour-long knowing better video about how
something we thought ended a century ago
actually didn't
[Music]
this video is brought to you by
curiositystream and nebula you're
telling me they invented a picture frame
that can show whatever image you want on
it will you get back in the closet man
this isn't really a topic for
light-hearted characters you're talking
about the civil war and you don't need
your civil war character we're actually
going to be talking about a whole lot
more than just the civil war but that's
irrelevant nobody cares about you most
people don't even know your name and
besides if i use you people are just
going to say that autumn shay did it
better
checkmate lincolnots you're right
okay well like the majority of my
audience i'm an american always have
been i went through elementary middle
and high school then i went on to
college to become a social studies
teacher and then i taught u.s history in
two different states at the middle and
high school level am i giving you my
credentials in order to brag
no quite the opposite actually i was
taught what i'm going to be calling the
standard american history myth
throughout all of my years of education
including college twice the story had
barely changed between the 1990s and
2010s and then i taught that same myth
to the next generation of students since
i'm going to be spending the rest of
this video dismantling this story and at
least some of my audience isn't american
it's probably a good idea to make sure
we're all on the same page as you can
see i have a brand new ish tv so i can
show you video clips whenever i want now
i found this video from an online
university that sums up what most of us
have been taught and therefore believe
about american history let me just
us history in four minutes or less
america was founded when a group of
protestant christians fleeing religious
persecution in europe made the harrowing
journey across the atlantic ocean and
landed at plymouth rock these pilgrims
had a feast with the indians to
celebrate their cooperation and that
became the holiday of thanksgiving over
the next few decades several other
british colonies were founded on the
american continent and in 1776 they all
declared their independence from the
king over the issue of taxation without
representation after the revolutionary
war had been won the founding fathers
wrote the constitution a freedom-loving
liberty document which guaranteed that
all men were created equal there's one
glaring hypocrisy with that statement
though the fact that slavery existed in
america how could the founding fathers
believe in equality while many of them
were also slave owners well many of them
knew that this peculiar institution was
morally wrong and thought that the
practice would naturally die out on its
own but just to be sure they put a
clause in the constitution saying that
the importation of new slaves would end
in 1808. none of the founding fathers
could have predicted the cotton gin
though which suddenly made slavery much
more profitable and all but guaranteed
it would continue for another century
throughout the 1800s abolitionists like
frederick douglass fought to end the
practice and in 1860 abraham lincoln was
elected on that very platform in order
to protect their rights as states and
keep their taxes from increasing several
southern states decided to break away
from the union and form their own
country known as the confederacy from
1861 to 1865 america fought the
bloodiest war in its history and in the
end the union was preserved and 4
million black people were freed from
bondage it's a common misconception that
abraham lincoln freed the slaves but the
emancipation proclamation only applied
to areas in active rebellion meaning the
confederate states there was no way to
enforce that without invading and the
northern slave states were unaffected so
this didn't really do much in reality it
wasn't the great emancipator but the
13th amendment ratified eight months
after his assassination that abolished
slavery reconstruction lasted from 1865
to 1877 and was marked by a period of
relative peace since federal troops were
stationed in the south to guarantee the
rights of the recently freed slaves
after reconstruction ended though things
got pretty dark pretty fast within a
decade black codes had been passed in
every southern state and many of them
required literacy tests and poll taxes
to vote this is the beginning of jim
crow an era where black people had to
sit at the back of the bus and drink out
of separate water fountains they even
had separate schools for white kids and
black kids that lasted until 1954 when
the supreme court decided to desegregate
public schools with the brown v board of
education decision this began the civil
rights movement which gave rise to
leaders like martin luther king who said
we should judge each other not by the
color of our skin but by the content of
our character with the passage of the
civil rights act of 1964 jim crow and
segregation were over and america had
finally swept away the last vestiges of
racism in the country we even elected a
black man as president
twice so the next time someone tells you
that america is a racist country with
racism in our dna hopefully now you'll
know better i'm no less better author if
you learned everything you need to know
about history in elementary school for
better university
thank you for watching to help keep
knowing better videos free subscribe to
our patreon page at patreon
i don't apologize for that nor do you
actually want an apology that was
hilarious you're probably familiar with
most of what was said in that video you
might have picked out a small inaccuracy
here or there but for the most part that
was the story you learned as a kid and
the one you likely still believe i know
that because that was the story i was
taught and the story i then taught to
others almost two decades later it's
also the story fake youtube universities
continue to push to this day
yes that was a prageru parody just about
every sentence was paraphrased from one
of their videos and they're usually
pushing the message that your kids are
learning something different and scary i
was spared the life sapping negative
messages about america that are
crippling a generation of young people
these ideas are poison as a social
studies teacher i can assure you that no
k-12 student is being taught that
america is a racist country or was
founded on racist ideals and they're
certainly not learning critical race
theory because if you stray from that
standard story you'll have an angry
parent on the phone by the afternoon and
you'll be talking to your superintendent
by the end of the week before you assume
anything that did not happen to me i 100
believed that version of american
history the entire time i worked in a
classroom
and honestly for years afterward but
that general story the standard myth
that america was founded on freedom
slavery ended after the civil war and
segregation lasted until martin luther
king
doesn't really explain the current state
of racial inequality and leaves a lot
more questions than answers i mean if
black people have been free for 150
years why is there still so much
inequality why haven't they caught up
yet you can come at this from multiple
different angles why do they perform
worse in school why do they make less
money why are they convicted of more
crime why aren't they elected to office
at a rate more proportional the point is
you're never given an answer to these
questions you're left to make it up on
your own if america is the land of
equality and some people just can't seem
to do well there must be something
inherently different about that group of
people specifically that prevents them
from succeeding most americans are never
taught that maybe the system itself is
rigged against them but even more than
that they never learned that the
fundamental premise of that question
that slavery ended 150 years ago
is incorrect i'm not talking about the
prison industrial complex or unpaid
internships i'm talking about ball and
chain chattel slavery if the standard
american history myth that we all grew
up hearing is wrong
when was the last slave freed in america
okay we don't need a second title card i
don't know why it did that before we can
get to your first guess the civil war
it's important to talk about the
political and societal situation leading
into it and correct several
misconceptions firstly america was not
founded by the pilgrims nor were they
fleeing any kind of religious
persecution but clearing up that
specific myth is a story for another
time jamestown virginia was the first
permanent british colony in america
founded in 1607. if you watched my
company towns video you're familiar with
this place it was a tobacco plantation
that began to use slave labor after a
workers strike in 1619. this is why the
1619 project marks this as the beginning
of america because it kind of is the
mayflower didn't happen until 1620. the
pilgrims had no intention of founding a
new country and the thanksgiving part
didn't get added to the story until way
later but again another time for decades
the various colonies in america existed
as somewhat mixed communities there were
free white people a few free black
people white indentured servants black
indentured servants and slaves who were
either black or native american that
lasted until bacon's rebellion in 1676
when most of these groups rebelled
against the ruling class because they
wanted to expand further west this was a
hundred years before independence the
colonies were ruled by the same
aristocracy that existed in britain and
in response to the uprising they decided
that the best way to keep the rabble in
line was to divide and conquer in the
years that followed virginia passed a
number of slave codes that stripped all
black people of any rights by 1705 there
were basically no free or indentured
black people in virginia they were no
longer considered citizens they couldn't
own property guns or employ a white
person this will be a recurring theme
going forward the laws in america were
used to force black people into an
underclass over the next two centuries
the rich white landowners of the south
including many of the founding fathers
relied on slave labor to keep their
economy going and at this point slavery
was still legal in every northern colony
as well in 1769 charles stewart traveled
with his slave james somerset from
massachusetts to england they lived
there for a few years until somerset
tried to escape and was imprisoned in
1772 his case was heard by lord
mansfield the chief justice of the
king's bench who determined the state of
slavery is of such a nature that it is
incapable of being introduced on any
reasons moral or political but only by
positive law
it is so odious that nothing can be
suffered to support it but positive law
whatever inconveniences therefore may
follow from the decision i cannot say
this case is allowed or approved by the
law of england and therefore the black
must be discharged basically what he
just said is that slavery is an
unnatural condition and can only exist
if there is a law specifically stating
it can exist that's what he means by
positive law there was no such law in
england therefore slavery cannot exist
there it's unclear who came up with this
famous line but it was said that the air
in england was so pure that if an
enslaved person were to breathe it in
they would instantly become free this
decision popularized the abolition and
anti-slavery movements which had quietly
existed for some time you know the next
part there's some spilled tea a few
lanterns in a window mel gibson and
eventually recognition of our
independence a few years after that the
founding fathers got together to write
the constitution there were 55 delegates
so there were disagreements on nearly
every issue among the noteworthy there
were abolitionists like john adams and
slave owners like thomas jefferson as a
result the issue of slavery appears in
the constitution three times without
ever actually using the word slavery
article 1 section 2 clause 3 states
representatives and direct taxes shall
be apportioned among the several states
which may be included within this union
according to their respective numbers
which shall be determined by adding the
whole number of free persons including
those bound to service for a term of
years and excluding indians not taxed
three-fifths of all other persons this
is the three-fifths compromise which we
all learn about in school two things to
note here first it doesn't say that
black people are only worth three-fifths
of a person it just says that
three-fifths of the total number shall
be counted which is basically the same
thing but worded slightly differently
secondly indentured servants still count
towards the population it was just
indians and other persons who are not it
wasn't the racists of the south who
wanted to can't slave populations less
than white populations it was the
abolitionists of the north
not sure why it keeps cutting to stuff
these old crts are kind of buggy anyway
she is right about that but why the
three-fifths compromise was a way for
the southern states to increase their
representation in congress and the
electoral college if they had their way
they would have counted all of the
people that they themselves did not
consider to be citizens that way they
could artificially inflate their
national political power the north would
have preferred to count none of them
because if they're not voting and they
don't have any rights who exactly are
you representing the second clause of
the constitution dealing with slavery is
article 1 section 9 clause 1. the
migration or importation of such persons
as any of the states now existing shall
think proper to admit shall not be
prohibited by the congress prior to the
year 1808
but attacks or duty may be imposed upon
such impartation not exceeding 10
dollars for each person i have
misunderstood and taught this clause of
the constitution incorrectly for years
children our founding fathers knew that
slavery was evil and wrong
and they knew that it would do terrible
harm to the nation our founders created
a system they thought would have slavery
in gradually
oh god was that like a kids video
no we're not doing this no more tv
okay well the founding fathers did not
know that slavery was evil and wrong
some of them actively participated in it
and fought for the various compromises
we're learning about right now they did
not create a system that would have it
end gradually this clause of the
constitution does not ban the
importation of new slaves go back and
read it it basically says congress shall
make no law abridging the slave trade
until 1808 which is exactly what
happened they banned it that year but
the point is the institution and
expansion of slavery was protected by
the constitution for the first 20 years
of its existence the founding fathers
did not plan for it to end that's just
how it happened to work out the final
mention of
i'm actually going to need the tv if
we're going to keep doing this
we'll just deal with the random clips i
guess
the final mention of slavery can be
found in article 4 section 2 clause 3.
no person held in service or labor in
one state under the laws thereof
escaping into another shall in
consequence of any law or regulation
therein be discharged from such service
or labor but shall be delivered up on
claim of the party to whom such service
or labor may be due this is the fugitive
slave clause which states that if an
enslaved person escapes to a free state
the slave owner can still hunt them down
and return them to bondage unlike in
britain in america breathing free air
does not automatically make one free i
just want to point out that the
constitution went out of its way to
include a direct response to the
somerset case stating that those
circumstances could never happen here
it's also important to remember that
america didn't exist in a vacuum things
were happening in other countries too
one such country was haiti a french
colony in the caribbean which used slave
labor to grow its sugar industry until
the slaves decided they had enough they
fought for 12 years and gained their
independence in 1804 after this
successful slave revolt two things
happened one america seemed to decide
that no matter what haiti would be
perpetually impoverished and two black
people couldn't read anymore if they
found out about haiti they might try
that here which is exactly what nat
turner did in virginia in 1831 so no
more reading while some states like
south carolina banned black literacy
during the colonial era most southern
states didn't enact similar laws until
the 1820s and 30s when the abolition
movement was really gaining steam as a
result we have very few first-hand
accounts of slavery written by the
actual slaves themselves most of their
stories are lost to history britain
abolished slavery in its overseas
territories in 1833 and while it's fun
to play alternate history and wonder if
that would have included america had the
revolution failed there's no way to know
for sure but this did include canada
which meant that the underground
railroad finally had a real destination
when frederick douglass escaped to new
york city in 1838 he was still subject
to the fugitive slave clause and could
be legally recaptured at any moment
rather than continue on to canada he
decided to become one of the country's
most prominent
abolitionists so you're trying to work
for change inside of the american system
precisely layla our system is wonderful
and the constitution is a glorious
liberty document oh no i forgot we were
on the kids one this is prageru
portraying frederick douglass as one of
the good ones for working within the
system to get slavery abolished which
immediately falls apart when you
remember that we had to fight a war i
can't take any more of the kids one let
me change the channel the movement's
leader william lloyd garrison burned the
constitution at his july 4th speeches in
garrison's view it legally protected
slavery and was therefore irredeemable
but douglas came to reject that he
believed that the constitution was
fundamentally opposed to slavery
interpreted as it ought to be
interpreted douglas said the
constitution is a glorious liberty
document
there's that line again glorious liberty
document personally i find william lloyd
garrison's argument to be a bit more
compelling especially considering those
three causes we just went over that
exclusively protected slavery but that
line actually comes from a speech
douglas gave in 1852 titled what to the
slave is the fourth of july what to the
american slave is your fourth july
i answer a day that reveals to him more
than all other days in the year
the gross injustice and cruelty to which
he is the constant victim
to him your celebration is a sham your
boasted liberty and unholy license
your national greatness swelling vanity
your sounds of rejoicing are empty and
heartless
your denunciations of tyrants brass
fronted impotence
your shouts of liberty and equality
hollow mockery your prayers and hymns
your sermons and thanksgivings
with all your religious parade and soul
anemone r to him mere bombast fraud
deception impurity and hypocrisy
they then veiled to cover up crimes
which would disgrace a nation of savages
there is not a nation on the earth
guilty of practices more shocking and
bloody than are the people of these
united states at this very hour
well that's rather scathing but not the
line i was looking for
in that instrument i hold there is
neither warrant license nor sanction of
the hateful thing
but interpret it as it ought to be
interpreted the constitution is a
glorious liberty document read its
preamble consider its purpose
is slavery among them
let me ask
if the constitution were intended to be
by its framers and adopters a
slave-holding instrument why neither
slavery slave holding nor slave can
anywhere be found in it
i mean just because it doesn't use the
word slave doesn't mean he's basically
making the somerset argument since the
constitution doesn't include a positive
law allowing for the institution of
slavery it shouldn't exist but it did so
look i'm just a former high school
teacher turned youtuber what do i know
what did the supreme court have to say
on the matter they're the ones who are
supposed to interpret the constitution
and figure out the framers original
intent throughout the 1840s and 50s dred
scott sued his owner for his freedom
multiple times he stated that since he
had been brought to the free state of
wisconsin he was now legally free again
referencing the somerset case the lower
courts went back and forth on the matter
until it reached the supreme court in
1857. i want you to stop for a moment
and remember back to what you were
taught about this case how is the
decision framed to you did they decide
that he was free or that he was a slave
here's the actual opinion from chief
justice tawny in the opinion of the
court the legislation and histories of
the times and the language used in the
declaration of independence showed that
neither the class of persons who had
been imported as slaves nor their
descendants whether they had become free
or not were then acknowledged as part of
the people nor intended to be included
in the general words used in that
memorable instrument
they had for more than a century before
been regarded as beings of an inferior
order and altogether unfit to associate
with the white race either in social or
political relations and so far inferior
that they had no rights which the white
man was bound to respect and that the
negro might justly and lawfully be
reduced to slavery for his benefit
and upon a full and careful
consideration of the subject the court
is of the opinion that upon the facts
stated in the plea and abatement dred
scott was not a citizen of missouri
within the meaning of the constitution
of the united states and not entitled as
such to sue in its courts so again was
dred scott a free man or a slave the
answer was neither he's not a citizen so
who cares black people had no rights to
which the white man was bound to respect
the declaration of independence was not
referring to them they were not created
equal they are not have never been and
will never be citizens of the united
states this was the highest court in the
land saying that the country's
foundational documents never meant to
include black people and it's phrased as
if this is just common sense at the time
in effect this was the government
telling douglas he was wrong the
constitution is not a glorious liberty
document at least not for people like
him just a few years earlier they passed
the fugitive slave act so not only could
slave catchers come get you if you were
in the north but northerners had to turn
you in if they knew you were a runway
this forced people in the north
including abolitionists to participate
in the slave trade under pain of
prosecution around this time we began to
see a shift in the way slaves were used
while the majority of them were still in
agriculture usually cotton sugar or
tobacco other industries began
experimenting with slave labor in 1850
the bib steam mill company a sawmill in
alabama owned 27 slaves and leased
others from surrounding farms this is
important because this is the beginning
of industrial slavery when corporations
owned people rather than just some rich
guy on a plantation railroad soon got
into the mix and by the beginning of the
civil war they collectively owned about
20 000 slaves so all right the civil war
which began after lincoln's election
because the southern states were worried
that he was going to possibly end
slavery or at the very least stop it
from expanding west it's a real bummer
that i have to take time out to explain
this but it's important our new
government is founded upon exactly the
opposite idea
its foundations are laid its cornerstone
rests upon the great truth that the
negro is not equal to the white man that
slavery subordination to the superior
race is his natural and normal condition
this our new government is the first in
the history of the world based upon this
great physical philosophical and moral
truth that was the vice president of the
confederacy saying that this is the
first government to be founded on the
idea that black people are subservient
to white people i mean arguably not
right like the united states anyway the
point is whether they were first or not
the confederacy was founded specifically
to defend the institution of slavery and
every state that seceded made sure to
mention that as they left at first
abraham lincoln had no real intention of
freeing the slaves this war was about
preserving the union my paramount object
in this struggle is to save the union
and is not either to save or destroy
slavery if i could save the union
without freeing any slave i would do it
and if i could save it by freeing all
the slaves i would do it and if i could
save it by freeing some and leaving
others alone i would also do that now
don't get it twisted abraham lincoln was
definitely against slavery but keeping
the united states united was more
important to him when he wrote that but
for the confederacy this war was
entirely about slavery from start to
finish the evidence is so clear and
overwhelming that it's almost impossible
to argue otherwise here i'll prove it to
you the evidence is clear and
overwhelming slavery was by a wide
margin the single most important cause
of the civil war did you think you'd
ever actually agree with prageru when
the various southern states seceded any
factories that were owned by northerners
were confiscated and transferred into
southern hands and those new owners
quickly staffed those mills and furnaces
with slave labor since all the white men
were off fighting the civil war caused a
dramatic increase in the use of
industrial slavery as soon as the war
began 40 slaves were put into the
sewanee mines and the empire state iron
and coal company put an ad in the local
newspaper looking to hire or buy 100
able-bodied hands within a few years the
shelby ironworks owned between 350 and
400 slaves and to cap it all off in 1863
the confederate government bought the
briarfield ironworks in alabama which
included nine black men listed on the
inventory under livestock just to
reiterate that that's the confederate
government itself owning slaves within a
few months of the outbreak of the war
the north passed the confiscation act of
1861 stating that any escaped slaves who
made it to the north were to be
considered captured enemy property or
contraband of war while still not
viewing them as people this was at least
the end of the fugitive slave act as the
war began to turn in the north's favor
lincoln entertained the idea of
abolishing slavery but didn't think that
the united states could continue to
exist as a mixed-race society so he
proposed recolonizing the former slaves
to central america to a place called
lincolnia if that sounds familiar it's
because this is the exact same thing
president monroe tried to do with
liberia this was just a new take on an
old idea this is where frederick
douglass has the most impact he
convinced lincoln out of the
recolonization plan and into the
emancipation proclamation which as
stated earlier wasn't really enforceable
and didn't really do much in terms of
freeing anyone but it did allow the
union army to enlist black people
douglas thought that if the united
states saw black men fighting for their
own freedom there was no way they could
deny their citizenship going forward two
of his sons ended up enlisting in the
54th massachusetts upon hearing about
the emancipation proclamation jefferson
davis the president of the confederacy
issued his own counter-proclamation
saying that any black soldiers they
capture will be returned to a state of
slavery or in practice executed the
emancipation proclamation went into
effect on january 1st 1863 and by the
time lincoln gave the gettysburg address
11 months later the entire purpose of
the war had shifted so many people had
died that lincoln began to wonder if
preserving the union was really worth
the human cost but if he could reframe
this war as the fight to free 4 million
black people who are being held in
chains
suddenly the death toll doesn't matter
as much the north was already starting
to win at this point but now they had a
renewed sense of purpose imagine going
from putting down a rebellion in a part
of the country you don't really care
about to ending slavery in terms of
righteous causes that's even better than
fighting for your own freedom in january
1865 when the 13th amendment was still
being discussed in congress general
sherman issued special field order 15.
this divided up 400 000 acres of
abandoned lands along the georgia coast
to be given to the freedmen which is
what we were calling former slaves
according to the order each family was
to get 40 acres and a mule and by june
of that year over 40 000 parcels of land
had been redistributed this is
reparations we actually did reparations
but don't get excited in march 1865 the
bureau of refugees freedmen and
abandoned lands was established more
commonly known as the freedmen's bureau
their primary job was to protect the
rights of recently freed slaves and help
them get their 40 acres the civil war
ended on april 9th and when abraham
lincoln suggested that black soldiers
who fought for the union should get the
vote
john wilkes booth decided to kill him as
a result on april 14 1865
andrew johnson became president he was a
southern democrat who remained loyal to
the union during the war and lincoln
chose him as vp as a sign of his
willingness to reconcile johnson also
happened to be a raging white
supremacist this is a country for white
men
and by god as long as i am president
it shall be a government for white men
within six months of his inauguration he
ordered the freedmen's bureau to return
all of the 40 acre plots that had been
distributed back to white ownership put
another way he confiscated the land and
undid reparations this was the beginning
of presidential reconstruction which was
supposed to be a rapid lenient
restoration of the union with as few
changes to the constitution as possible
once the 13th amendment was ratified he
thought that should be the end of it
just to recap the timeline here the war
ended in april 1865 the last remnants of
the confederacy surrendered on june 19th
and the 13th amendment was ratified in
december of that year what do you think
happened after that the friedman just
walked off into the sunset end of movie
role credits obviously not right the
south still needed to harvest crops and
they weren't about to let four million
laborers just go free and do whatever
many of the freedmen ended up working on
the same plantations that used to own
them as slaves the planter class had
them sign labor contracts which often
included slave-like conditions they
agreed to be locked in a cell or chained
up at night not leave the property obey
commands speak in a servile manner and
accept whatever punishment was deemed
necessary why would anyone sign these
because black literacy had been illegal
for decades most of them couldn't read
by the end of the next year most of
these contracts were dissolved by the
occupying union commanders because it
was obvious that the south was just
trying to bring back slavery it was
clear to congress at least that much
more needed to be done the civil rights
act of 1866 declared all persons born in
the united states to be full-fledged
citizens regardless of race or previous
condition of servitude johnson vetoed
the bill and for the first time ever
congress voted to override that and push
it through anyway if the wording of that
act sounds familiar that's because it
was eventually replaced by the 14th
amendment which didn't get ratified
until 1868. andrew johnson denounced the
amendment as usurping state authority
the reconstruction act of 1867 ended
johnson's plan and began radical
reconstruction when the former
confederate states were divided up into
five military districts each commanded
by a general who enforced the law it
also required the new southern
governments to ratify the 14th amendment
as you probably guessed andrew johnson
also vetoed this bill and again it was
overridden by congress and as a result
38 000 federal troops were stationed in
the south half of whom were black and as
a further result of this law the ku klux
klan consolidated power and became much
more active the kkk was formed on
christmas eve 1865 but can trace its
origins back to when the confederate
government established militias known as
home guards to patrol the countryside
looking for deserters and runaway slaves
when the war ended these home guards
began a guerrilla campaign against union
troops and eventually turned to
terrorism entire families of freedmen
were lynched the only way the former
slaves were going to be guaranteed their
safety and freedom was with the presence
of tens of thousands of federal troops
during the election of 1868 they stood
guard outside of every polling place in
the south with the end of the
three-fifths compromise southern
representation in congress was about to
dramatically increase so
they were required to allow black men to
vote even though black people still
couldn't vote in most states in the
north because the 15th amendment
wouldn't be ratified until 1870. federal
troops stationed in the south helped
secure rights for the newly freed slaves
hundreds of black men were elected to
southern state legislatures as
republicans and 22 black republicans
served in the u.s congress by 1900 i
want you to remember that she stopped
counting in 1900 once you have that
locked away she is right in 1870 1500
black politicians began serving in state
and federal office almost all of them
were republicans because it was the
party of lincoln obviously hiram revels
was the first black us senator a
republican from mississippi believe it
or not that same year the federal
government declared the kkk to be a
terrorist organization and after a riot
in south carolina president ulysses s
grant declared martial law and suspended
habeas corpus for any suspected members
this completely destroyed the ku klux
klan by 1872
you won't believe what brought them back
but we'll get to that the presidential
election of 1876
split the popular and electoral vote a
situation we're all too familiar with
these days as a result we ended up with
the compromise of 1877. southern
democrats who now held a majority in
congress would accept republican
rutherford b hayes as president in
return for the removal of federal troops
from the south have you noticed that all
of our compromises just end up being
concessions to the south this was the
definitive end of reconstruction without
federal troops or the freedmen's bureau
around white supremacist violence and
intimidation was allowed to run wild but
more importantly southern governments
were free to do whatever they wanted
immediately after the civil war and
throughout reconstruction every southern
state enacted what would later become
known as black codes we all learn about
these in school right but can you
actually describe a black code my guess
is you probably have this confused with
an early form of segregation they
weren't allowed in certain public spaces
interracial marriage was outlawed that
kind of stuff or maybe you think this
restricted voting or property rights
with measures like black codes
laws that restricted the ability of
blacks to own property and run
businesses
and they impose poll taxes and literacy
tests
used to subvert black citizens right to
vote most of that stuff doesn't come
along until way later so
what is a black code these were a set of
laws written in a colorblind fashion
making it a crime for everyone but in
practice they were only ever illegal for
black people which is probably why we
don't really learn about these in school
this is somewhat uncomfortable to talk
about because we think of the law as
neutral if it says murder is illegal
it's illegal for everyone
but we're not talking about violence or
theft here the black codes were
basically made up social crimes most of
which were victimless the most important
and egregious one was vagrancy which is
the act of being unemployed usually
defined as when a laborer or servant
loiters away his time do you see why so
many of the recently freed slaves signed
labor contracts with their former owners
many states imposed fines on or made it
illegal for black people to work in any
industry other than agriculture or
domestic service so congratulations
you're free to do whatever you want
as long as it's the thing you were
already doing as a slave it was also
against the law to quit your job or
break a labor contract which was
prosecuted as fraud or false pretenses
as they called it in many states as a
white person you couldn't hire a
freedman without proper discharge
paperwork from their previous employer
this meant that as a black person in the
south you had to have a white person who
could speak for you as your employer or
at the very least former employer if you
didn't have that protection you ran the
risk of being arrested for vagrancy
since the road system in the south
wasn't very robust if you wanted to get
from one place to another the easiest
way was to hop on a freight train which
was illegal without a ticket the second
easiest way was to walk alongside the
track which was trespassing gambling
drinking and even carrying a concealed
weapon were crimes for black people only
that can include anything from a gun to
a knife to a razor using obscene or
offensive language or talking too loudly
in the presence of a white woman was
illegal remember this i'm gonna tell
them there's an african-american man
threatening my life this has been going
on for over 150 years white women have
always held a special power over black
men interracial sexual relations were
illegal but only if it was a black man
with a white woman and even then only
the black man was punished they
prosecuted that under misogynation or
adultery depending on the circumstances
many states also passed what were called
pig laws elevating what would have been
a petty crime to the level of a felony
stealing a pig worth one dollar would
get you five years in prison the theft
of an eight cent fence post was enough
to get you sentenced to hard labor and
now we're getting to the point because
as soon as these laws were in place the
south began to use the black codes to
transition away from slavery and towards
convict labor you probably think i'm
talking about chain gangs but those
don't happen until much later before the
civil war the judicial system was
exclusively designed for white people if
a black person committed a crime i'm
sorry to say but it was viewed the same
way as your dog committing a crime they
were chattel property so punishment was
left to the owner even after the war
prisons were few and far between only
the worst crimes were punished with jail
time most of the black codes just
involved a fine or hard labor so these
laws weren't designed to put black
people behind bars they were designed to
put them to work the first system i want
to talk about is convict leasing it's
one of those things that we all learn
about eventually usually by watching the
shawshank redemption which while being a
good example is also an extremely
sanitized one to truly understand how
this scheme played out we have to let go
of all of our modern ideas of how the
criminal justice system is supposed to
work at this point in history police
departments barely existed and even then
only in major cities do you know what a
notary public is there's someone
entrusted by the government to witness
signatures on contracts you can find
them in banks post offices grocery
stores hell some of you watching this
might even be a notary public well back
in the day justices of the peace
functioned in the same way they were
innkeepers tailors and even plantation
owners who adjudicated crime at the
county level which was most crime at
this point it was rare for the state or
federal government to get involved
county law enforcement was handled by an
elected sheriff but this was usually
just an administrative role the actual
work was done by appointed deputies who
could be store keepers grocers and again
plantation owners can you figure out
what's about to happen here a sheriff's
deputy a bounty hunter or sometimes just
a random white person would seize a
black man walking along a railroad track
and take him to the nearest justice of
the peace tavern owner the justice would
invariably find them guilty of something
they would impose a fine or sentence
them to hard labor which basically
allowed the government to sell the
convict to the highest bidder in 1866
both alabama and texas leased hundreds
of their prisoners to railroad companies
within a few years mississippi convicts
were back working on cotton plantations
and tennessee had sent theirs across the
border into the mines of birmingham by
the time reconstruction ended every
southern state and county had a convict
leasing program they didn't really
generate much revenue for the government
but they were seen as a benefit because
it saved them from having to pay for
housing and food for the prisoners the
main purpose of convict leasing was to
keep the southern economy moving with a
nearly free labor force birmingham
alabama was founded in 1871 as a steel
manufacturing hub for the south but its
origins traced back to when the
confederacy financed the first blast
furnaces and put slaves in the various
coal mines this is a natural
continuation of the industrial slavery
we were talking about earlier after the
war ended companies like tennessee coal
iron and rail switched from leasing
slaves from nearby farms to leasing
convicts from the government on march
30th 1908 green cottonham was arrested
for riding a freight train without a
ticket when no evidence or witnesses
could be produced to support that charge
the judge declared him guilty of
vagrancy he was sentenced to three
months of hard labor extended to six
months and six days to cover the court
fees shelby county alabama then leased
him to the tennessee coal iron and rail
company which put him to work on slope
number 12 of the pratt mines near
birmingham they paid the county 12 a
month for his labor he died of disease
five months into his sentence tennessee
coal iron and rail entered into its
first convict leasing contract with the
state of alabama in 1888 paying anywhere
from 9 to 18 a month depending on the
prisoner by 1900 there would be over a
thousand convicts working the mines less
than 70 of which were white it's easy
not to care about these people because
they're criminals right if you don't
want to do hard labor maybe don't commit
crimes but it's worth asking what these
people did that got them there in 1890
alabama conducted a survey of all the
convicts they sent into the pratt mines
among the felonies there were 11 for
false pretense which is quitting your
job or breaking a labor contract seven
for bigamy six for miscegenation which
is interracial sexual relations four for
homosexuality and two for illegal voting
among the misdemeanors there were 94 for
petty theft 46 for carrying a concealed
weapon 24 for false pretense 24 for
obscene language 19 for gambling 13 for
selling whiskey eight not given don't
worry we'll come back to that seven for
vagrancy five for violating a contract
with a white employer three for
bastardry and two for selling cotton
after sunset selling cotton after sunset
i thought this was america how could the
time of day affect the legality of the
free exchange of goods and services it
didn't after sunset was code whenever
you see that just substitute it with the
phrase for black people this is how
sundown towns worked because they
obviously couldn't pass a law explicitly
stating that black people weren't
welcome they had to make it a crime to
just
do something after sunset these sunset
laws are still on the books in many
places you'll often find them on lists
of the weirdest laws from every state it
really changes your perspective when you
find out what these crimes actually were
carrying a razor in your pocket walking
along a railroad or quitting your job
i've literally done all of those things
and i would never expect to go to prison
for them you probably noticed while
going over that list that there weren't
any violent crimes people were being
sentenced to hard labor for swearing or
gambling john clark was convicted of
gaming on april 11 1903 the usual
punishment would have been 10 days of
hard labor but because of court fees
that was extended to 114 days and he was
leased to the kohlberg mine he died
after 34 days when he was crushed by
falling rock i don't know about you but
i don't think the punishment for rolling
dice on the sidewalk should be hard
manual labor until death the kohlberg
mine alone had an annual convict death
rate of 30 percent but as bad as that
sounds convict leasing was not limited
to coal mines counties often rented out
their prisoners to any farmer or
plantation owner who could afford them
which thanks to this new system was
basically everyone slaves used to cost
hundreds even thousands of dollars they
were so expensive that only the richest
plantation owners could participate in
the trade but leasing a convict only
costs a few bucks a month even poor
farmers can afford that and unlike the
old days there was no incentive to keep
your black laborer at least somewhat
healthy you could literally just work
them to death and then get a new one
tomorrow this isn't just my enlightened
historical perspective the department of
justice held the same opinion over a
hundred years ago this system is more
cruel and inhuman than the slavery of
antebellum days
since then the master conserved the life
and health of the slave for business
reasons just as he did that of his horse
or mule but now the master treated the
slave unmercifully and with the sole
object of getting the greatest possible
amount of labor out of them moreover a
convict costs but a few dollars while a
slave used to cost several hundred
here's where i need to introduce another
important concept known as debt peonage
which is when a person compels a laborer
to work or holds them in servitude to
pay off a debt i know that a lot of you
are immediately going to think i'm
talking about sharecropping and i'm not
just briefly sharecropping was when a
landlord would let a tenant farmer work
a piece of their property in exchange
for a share of the final crop while
sharecroppers often fell into debt
especially after a bad season they were
still technically free
and mostly white debt peonage is when
you owe me 10
and you're basically my slave until you
pay it off this is the same basic idea
behind convict leasing you owe money to
the state or county so you work it off
with hard labor but let's say you owe a
fine and you can't pay it you don't want
to be sent to the mines but you're in
luck the sheriff's deputy who arrested
you is also a plantation owner he's
willing to pay your fine for you as long
as you're willing to work off the debt
on his farm you sign a labor contract
for nine months
not realizing you also just agreed to be
locked up at night and pay for your own
recapture should you try to escape keep
in mind that since your debt to the
state has been settled you're
technically not a criminal anymore
you're just a laborer who has agreed to
be treated like one meanwhile all the
food clothing housing and medicine
you're being provided with is adding to
your debt and increasing your time at
this rate it's going to take years to
pay off that fine so all right let's say
you'd rather avoid all that and fight
the charge you didn't do anything wrong
they can't prove anything good luck with
that you have no right to an attorney
that doesn't start until 1964. you're a
black man and you stand accused by a
white sheriff's deputy and the white
justice of the peace has unilateral
authority to declare you guilty it is a
foregone conclusion that you will be
convicted of something even more than
that the longer the trial goes on and
the more witnesses that are called the
higher the fine will be when you lose
and you will lose which is why by the
1880s the obscure legal practice of
confessing judgment had become popular
this is when you plead guilty to a
lesser charge and accept a lesser
punishment because fighting it and going
to trial would make things much worse
for you nowadays we call this plea
bargaining but this is where it started
remember those eight people who were
convicted of not given and sent into the
pratt mines
this is what happened to them they just
pled guilty the court didn't even bother
to write down for what crime because it
didn't matter in 1898 the largest
criminal category for convict laborers
in alabama was not given in september
1901 john davis was arrested for
vagrancy when that charge could not be
proven he was judged guilty of obtaining
goods under false pretense in order to
pay a fine of 75
a man named john w pace paid his fine
for him and they signed a 10-month labor
contract after 12 months on pace's
plantation davis was sold to another
farmer for fifty dollars it's unclear
how long he was held there john davis
was arrested by a man named robert
franklin and judged by a justice of the
peace named james kennedy
both of whom were employed by john w
pace in may 1903 the department of
justice announced an investigation into
pace's slavery ring and john davis would
eventually testify at the trial here's
how the federal prosecutor in the case
warren reese described the scheme in his
own
and words on the part of wealthy and
influential men these violations have
not been confined to one or two
periodical and independent instances but
it has developed into a miserable
business and custom to catch up ignorant
and helpless negro men and women upon
the flimsiest and most baseless charges
carry them before a justice of the peace
is usually a paid hireling of these
wealthy dealers the victim is found
guilty and the fine is assessed which in
the beginning cannot be paid by the
victim and then it is that one of these
slave dealers steps up pretends to be
the friend of the negro telling him he
will pay him out if he will sign a
contract to work for him on his farm the
negro readily agrees rather than go to
the mines as he is informed he will have
to do his fine is paid the contract is
signed and the negro was taken to the
farm or mine or mill or quarry of the
employer placed into a condition of
involuntary servitude he is locked up at
night in the cell worked under guards
during the day from three o'clock in the
morning till seven or eight o'clock at
night whipped in a most cruel manner is
insufficiently fed or poorly clad in
fact the evidence in nearly all the
cases investigated reveals that the
negro men are worked nearly naked while
the women are worked in an equally
disgraceful manner brutal things have
transpired and sometimes death has
resulted from the infliction of corporal
punishment if they run away the dogs are
placed upon their track and they are
invariably retaken and subjected to more
cruel treatment when the time of a good
working negro is nearing an end he is
re-arrested upon some trumped-up charge
and again carried before some brab
justice and re-sentenced to an
additional time in this way negroes have
been known to have worked in these
places and in this situation for years
and years they can get no word to
friends nor is word allowed to reach
them from the outside world they are
held in abject slavery without any
knowledge of what goes on in the outside
world the indictments so far found are
based upon some 25 negro men and women
who have been the subjects of these
violations these are some of the most
severe instances but it has been
discovered that there are hundreds of
other cases
i know what you're thinking oh well it
was only a few hundred people that
doesn't sound that bad nope in the years
after the civil war over 800 000 people
were caught up in this system this was
one indictment in one county in one
state and there were hundreds of victims
during this same period there were
similar cases being heard in georgia
florida texas basically everywhere to
put that in perspective we freed four
million black people and then
re-enslaved a fifth of them as convicts
and debt peons and before you go
thinking that these cases had a happy
ending remember the primary question of
this video when was the last slave freed
in america if you hadn't noticed you
still don't have an answer to that
question john w pace and his
co-conspirators were charged with
violating the federal anti-people
statute which was passed in 1867 to
abolish the surf-like conditions that
existed in the new mexico territory when
we acquired all of that land from mexico
we also acquired the societal structure
of the people living there so we got rid
of the peonage system and then gave away
free land to anyone willing to move
there during the various homestead acts
which were kind of like reparations but
only for white people
and they weren't really making up for
anything it was just kind of a bonus
anyway pace and his friend's actual
defense was that since the debts that
were owed to them were fictitious this
wasn't pionege it was slavery and
slavery wasn't illegal
and they were right their charges were
dismissed or they got off on appeal most
of the other cases around the country
fell apart for the same reason because
believe it or not slavery was not a
crime the 13th amendment to the
constitution says neither slavery nor
involuntary servitude except as
punishment for a crime blah blah shall
exist within the united states or any
place subject to their jurisdiction you
know what it doesn't say anyone caught
engaging in slavery is guilty of a
felony and shall serve blah blah in
prison blah blah it abolished slavery as
a legal concept but didn't provide any
punishment for continuing the practice
anyway it does include a section that
says congress shall have power to
enforce this article by appropriate
legislation but congress never got
around to doing that john w pace renewed
his leasing contract with the county and
was found to be holding slaves on his
property less than a year later
and there was nothing anybody could do
about it as a result this neo-slavery
disguised as debt peonage was allowed to
continue for decades if you're not
seething with anger right now you need
to look at yourself in the mirror and
ask yourself why that is
[Music]
as i mentioned this wasn't isolated to
the coal mines and cotton plantations of
alabama convict debt peons were cutting
sugar cane in texas harvesting
turpentine in florida and working at the
infamous chattahoochee brick company in
georgia where they like to use child
convicts because they were small enough
to fit inside of the kilns after public
hearings on corruption and conditions
within their leasing system the state of
georgia decided to abolish their program
in 1909 martin tabor was arrested for
vagrancy in the winter of 1921 he was
found guilty and was imposed a fine of
his family actually sent the money but
by the time it arrived he had already
been leased to a turpentine camp in
florida on a three-month contract
shortly afterwards he was whipped over a
hundred times by an overseer and died of
his wounds normally this wouldn't change
anything this happened literally every
day all over the south but martin taber
was a rich white kid from north dakota
he was a 22 year old on a cross-country
backpacking trip when he was arrested
his family pressed charges and the
resulting media frenzy caused such a
nationwide outrage that florida ended
its convict leasing system in 1923
alabama didn't end their program until
1928 making them the last state to do so
in that final year the state had over 37
000 prisoners leased out to various
companies and plantations 12 500 of
which were sentenced to hard labor for
the sale or possession of alcohol
because at this point prohibition was a
thing
2735 were in for vagrancy 2014 for
gaming 458 for leaving a farm without
permission and 154 for adultery and
miscegenation once a state ended its
convict leasing program they
transitioned to using prison labor on
state projects like roads and highways
these are the chain gangs you're
familiar with they start in the 1920s
and 30s meanwhile county convict leasing
systems and the debt peonage scheme we
discussed earlier which is just slavery
with extra steps continue to exist
without any real challenges you've seen
the length of this video you know we're
not done yet while every us history
teacher will correctly tell you that
reconstruction ended in 1877 it took a
few years for the reforms of that era to
be dismantled usv crook shank and the
slaughterhouse cases basically gutted
the 14th amendment without the presence
of union troops and without action from
the federal government southern state
governments quickly stripped friedman of
all of their rights and refused to
protect them from mob violence for
almost a century after the civil war
white on black crime went virtually
unpunished in 1883 the supreme court
ruled that the civil rights act of 1875
which prohibited racial discrimination
in public accommodations like
restaurants and transportation was
unconstitutional here's the majority
opinion from that case when a man has
emerged from slavery and by the aid of
beneficent legislation has shaken off
the inseparable confidence of that state
there must be some stage in the progress
of his elevation when he takes the rank
of a mere citizen and ceases to be the
special favorite of the laws and when
his riots as a citizen or a man are to
be protected in the ordinary modes by
which other men's rats are protected
less than 20 years after the civil war
and they're already making the oh come
on slavery ended forever ago argument
this decision allowed segregation at the
state level in 1892 homer plessy boarded
a train and sat in the white section
with the full intention of being
arrested and challenging louisiana's
separate car act plessy was only 1 8
black that's one great grandparent and
that was enough to put him in the
colored section as you're probably aware
in 1896 the supreme court sided with
louisiana and gave federal approval for
segregation to become the norm across
the country even the north was on board
with segregation at this point you see
before the civil war the racial
hierarchy had been justified using the
bible it had been ordained by god have
you ever wondered why there's a southern
baptist church because in 1845 they
broke away from the rest of the baptists
over the issue of slavery and the
teaching that god stained their skin
black as a permanent mark of servitude
southern ministers told the slaves that
theirs was a glorified place among the
chickens and the pigs in 1859 darwin
came out with his book on the origin of
species and it didn't take long for
amateur scientists to start measuring
skulls and determining which race was
superior
care to guess which one they chose this
was the beginning of the eugenics
movement it's sometimes difficult to
remember that all of these things were
happening at the same time and during
the 1870s the indian wars were in full
swing which spawned an entire genre of
literary fiction which told fantastic
tales of white men civilizing the west
manifest destiny provided americans with
an idealized view of white progress and
then to top it all off northerners were
bombarded with the news out of the south
regarding an apparent crime wave
following the abolition of slavery this
was a result of the black codes which
were presented as neutral while the
freedmen were presented as violent
criminals if you were to ask a white
northerner to describe a black person in
the 1850s before the civil war they
would have used words like loyal dutiful
reliable hard-working and trustworthy
while still servile in nature i hope we
can agree that these are mostly positive
traits by the 1890s when convict leasing
and debt peonage were widely practiced
they were a threat uncivilized demonic a
lascivious beast roaming the country
this is it if you learn nothing else
from this video i want this to be it
southern whites used laws like vagrancy
trespassing and false pretense to
convince northern whites that black
people were incapable of living in
civilized society this is where the myth
of black criminality comes from this is
decades before the war on drugs if that
doesn't piss you off i want you to take
out your phone turn on the camera flip
it to selfie mode and then ask yourself
why that is my guess is it's because
none of the history i've talked about so
far would have ever applied to you given
all of that is it really that much of a
surprise that when birth of a nation was
released in 1915
everyone north and south bought its
message this was the first
feature-length american film and quickly
became the first hollywood blockbuster
in the film the abolition of slavery is
depicted as a mistake unleashing
animalistic black men on our
unsuspecting innocent white women the
kkk are the heroes swooping in to save
the south and restore order this
confirmed the story that white people
wanted to hear and turn the defeat of
the confederacy into a tale of martyrdom
this rewrite of american history is
known as the lost cause and is still
pushed by textbooks today this movie is
also directly responsible for the
rebirth of the ku klux klan who began
terrorizing black families by burning
crosses on their lawns the original kkk
didn't do that that was invented by the
movie i told you you wouldn't believe
what brought them back frederick
douglass died in 1895 which meant that
the most influential black leader was
now booker t washington who pushed a
more gradualist message he urged black
people to accommodate white demands for
subservience while building up their
skills he told them to learn a trade to
hold the keys to their own advancement
and not move up north don't worry white
people will come around eventually
needless to say this message was praised
by many southern whites by 1901 they had
gradually disenfranchised every black
person in the south by passing laws and
writing new state constitutions they
obviously couldn't ban an entire race
from voting because of the 15th
amendment instead they instituted poll
taxes and literacy tests to accomplish
the same goal you all know about these
even prageru mentions them but just like
the black codes you probably have a very
watered down understanding of them let's
start with the literacy tests nearly
every state required you to know how to
read and write if you wanted to vote
which sounds reasonable on the surface
right here's an actual literacy test
from the state of louisiana it starts
off with some fairly straightforward
questions draw a line around the number
or letter of this sentence cross out the
longest word circle the first first
letter of the alphabet simple but then
you get to number ten in the first
circle below write the last letter of
the first word beginning with l
what number 12 draw a line from circle 2
to circle 5 that will pass below circle
2 and above circle come on this is only
the first page there are 30 total
questions and one wrong answer denotes
failure of this test now be honest is
that what you thought a literacy test
was when you learned about it in school
because i'm willing to bet this was
never explained to you these tests were
arbitrarily given out to anyone who
couldn't prove a fifth grade education
and the questions were just vague enough
that any answer could be subjectively
wrong many states also put up financial
barriers to voting mississippi required
a poll tax of three dollars which is
just over a hundred in today's money
would you vote if it costs you that much
to do it every time
i doubt it virginia's was only one
dollar but you had to be paying it for
each of the previous three years before
you could vote louisiana required you to
own at least 300 in property but
included an exemption for anyone who
could vote on january 1st 1867 or their
descendants this is the origin of the
phrase grandfather clause this loophole
was intended to let poor white people
vote even if they didn't meet the
literacy or financial requirements as
long as their grandfather was allowed to
vote virtually no black people were
voting in the south in 1867 so their
descendants didn't qualify
disenfranchisement has several knock-on
effects that you might not immediately
think about it's a lot more than just
your ability to vote you'll also find it
near impossible to run for office this
obviously meant that there were no black
representatives in state or federal
government which is why the nice prageru
ladies stopped counting them in 1900 but
this also affected local office there
were no black sheriffs constables or
justices of the peace not being
registered to vote also means that you
couldn't be called for jury duty so
black defendants were almost always
tried and convicted by all white juries
by the time birth of a nation and
woodrow wilson came around black people
had been almost entirely pushed out of
government confederate statues were
being put up in the north and south and
the lost cause had completely taken over
the historical narrative race riots
occurred in places like springfield
illinois charleston south carolina and
tulsa oklahoma lynching had become so
popular that children were let out of
school early so they could attend and
newspapers advertised the event days
beforehand people took selfies with the
deceased and left with souvenirs and
postcards the violence around the
country got so bad that in 1936 victor
greene began publishing the negro
motorists green book a travel guide with
a list of hotels gas stations and barber
shops that are friendly to black people
in every city they were working on a
fictional version of this in the first
season of lovecraft country this was
based on a real thing these were printed
all the way through the civil rights
movement and ended in 1966. think about
what that means for a moment this
country was so hostile to black people
that for three decades they needed to
have their own separate travel guide
where every listed location had to be
vetted for safety because if you went
into the wrong town you might disappear
forever
mr vice president
mr speaker
yesterday
december 7th
if you're wondering what fdr has to do
with slavery i'm guessing you've
forgotten the primary question of this
video
again after giving that speech president
roosevelt asked his cabinet what the
enemy was going to use against the
united states in the coming propaganda
war the answer was the treatment of the
negro in addition to disenfranchisement
and segregation the convict leasing debt
peonage system was still holding
thousands of people in bondage a man
named charles bledsoe pled guilty to
peonage in mobile alabama in october
1941 just two months before pearl harbor
america could hardly claim the moral
high ground or point fingers at how
japan was treating the chinese or
koreans when we had our own subjugated
underclass so on december 12 1941 fdr's
justice department issued circular 3591
a summary of the department files on
alleged peonage violations discloses
numerous instances of prosecution denied
by united states attorneys the main
reason stated as being the absence of
the element of debt in the matter of
control by one over the person of
another the circumstances under which
each person is placed must be determined
i.e the subservience of the will of one
to the other open force threats or
intimidation need not be used to cause a
person to go involuntarily from one
place to another to work and to remain
at such work nor does evidence of kind
treatment show an absence of involuntary
servitude in the united states one
cannot sell himself as a peon or a slave
the law is fixed and established to
protect the weak-minded the poor the
miserable men will sometimes sell
themselves for a meal of vittles or
contract with another who acts as surety
on his bond to work out the amount of
the bond upon his release from jail any
such contract is positively null and
void and the procuring and causing of
such contract to be made violates the
law to assure emphasis on the issue of
involuntary servitude and slavery in
considering these cases the federal
bureau of investigation has been
requested to change the title on its
reports from peonage to read involuntary
servitude and slavery this memo told
prosecutors to stop trying these cases
under the federal anti-peonage statute
because so many people were using the
same defense as john w pace that since
the debt wasn't real this wasn't peonage
it was slavery and slavery wasn't a
crime they were told to stop calling it
pianage and start calling it what it is
slavery the memo provided them with a
list of other statutes that could apply
and told them to aggressively prosecute
these crimes as part of the war effort
over the next few months dozens of cases
would be opened across the country in
september 1942 on a farm outside of
beeville texas a man named alfred irving
became the last chattel slave to be
freed in america not indentured servant
or convict laborer or debt peon
slave here's a news article from the
time saying as much the scribarchic
family held him as a slave for at least
four years they starved him and beat him
with chains whips and ropes so regularly
that he was permanently disfigured the
family was found guilty and sentenced to
federal prison the corpus christi times
said that the trial and its conclusion
will undoubtedly be said in the future
to have given a decisive setback to the
enemy propaganda machine so in a way by
bombing pearl harbor the japanese ended
slavery in the united states when people
noticed the obvious inequality in our
country and wonder why black people
haven't caught up yet despite slavery
ending over 150 years ago they're wrong
it ended 80 years ago when was the last
slave freed in america it wasn't after
the civil war it was during world war ii
in september 1942 our current president
joe biden was born two months later
until he graduated from college black
people had to drink out of a separate
water fountain segregation didn't end
until the civil rights act of 1964. jim
crow ended with the voting rights act of
1965 which allowed black people to vote
again but just a few years after that
nixon came along with his war on drugs
which disenfranchised and imprisoned
even more black people on purpose my
police militarization video goes into
more detail but if you don't believe me
the nixon campaign in 1968 and the nixon
white house after that had two enemies
the anti-war left and black people you
understand what i'm saying we knew we
couldn't make it illegal to be either
against the war or black but by getting
the public to associate the hippies with
marijuana and the blacks with heroin and
criminalizing both heavily we could
disrupt those communities we could
arrest their leaders raid their homes
break up their meetings and vilify them
night after night on the evening news
did we know we were lying about the
drugs of course we did why haven't we
done reparations we clearly owe them and
by we i don't mean white people i mean
the government of the united states
since the colonial days the laws of this
country have been used to force black
people into a permanent underclass for
the first hundred years after
independence the constitution not only
allowed but protected slavery and
immediately after it was abolished the
criminal justice system was used as
leverage to extract as much labor and
wealth out of black people as possible
either directly by sentencing them to
hard labor in the coal mines or
indirectly by issuing an exorbitant fine
that was then paid for by a plantation
owner who held that debt over them while
simultaneously increasing it so it took
years to pay off if they tried to leave
they'd be arrested for breaking a labor
contract and given even more hard labor
this blatantly unjust system created
generations of people who rightfully
fear going out alone and have learned
not to expect help from the authorities
they don't trust the police and have
lost all faith in the criminal justice
system and who can blame them for almost
a hundred years the primary purpose of
the judicial system was to coerce black
people into meeting the labor demands
and social customs of the white majority
this created a century-old myth about
black criminality that persists to this
day the government of the united states
did that not some slave owners who died
over 150 years ago and they arguably
continue to do it with the war on drugs
joe biden was instrumental in
introducing the modern version of pig
laws when he was in the senate we went
from slave codes and chattel slavery to
black codes and neo-slavery which is
convict leasing and debt peonage to the
war on drugs and the prison industrial
complex it's basically a continuum of
oppression against black people this
version of history otherwise known as
what actually happened explains much
more about the current state of racial
inequality in our country than the
standard american history myth we were
all taught have you noticed i haven't
shown you a prageru clip in the last
half hour because this part of the story
is almost always skipped over we learn
about the pilgrims the revolution the
civil war and that's pretty much it
you'll eventually learn about
segregation and how martin luther king
ended racism also in our time all
americans are equally protected under
the law and have equal voting rights
regardless of race we even had a black
president two terms
today america is the most successful
multi-racial country in history the only
white majority country to elect a black
president twice prageru is basically
presenting the same version of history
that we all learned in elementary in
high school the only difference is that
their target audience consists entirely
of adults specifically parents they're
pushing for school choice so they're
trying to scare parents into believing
their kids are learning critical race
theory or that america is a racist
country but i can assure you
no child is learning about anything i've
talked about during this video there are
history and social studies teachers
watching this right now who have never
heard about debt peonage before i know i
hadn't when i was a teacher finally
learning about this stuff has given me a
serious crisis of conscience i was
taught the standard american history
myth which is just a watered-down
version of the lost cause and then i
helped spread that narrative to the next
generation of kids as an educator there
is nothing worse than realizing you've
been teaching a lie even if it's only a
lie by omission the full story makes so
much more sense that i wish this stuff
was taught in school because then we
might actually demand some changes which
is exactly why prageru keeps telling you
the same story you learned in 5th grade
history is the only subject where they
repeatedly say you shouldn't learn
anything new because then you might feel
bad about being white or american you
learned everything you need to know
about history in elementary school i
don't feel any guilt for being white but
i do feel guilty that i believed the
fairytale version of american history
for so long
at least now i know better and so do you
now that you know all this it's time to
confront your implicit racial biases
which you can do over at
curiositystream.com knowing better
curiosity stream is a subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction titles
that you can access across multiple
platforms are you racist find out by
watching the show are you racist which
ran multiple subjects through a battery
of psychological tests to reveal
subconscious prejudices against certain
other people do you think some people
are just genetically more likely to
commit crime this documentary is for you
check it out by heading over to
curiositystream.com
knowingbetter where you can also get
access to nebula the streaming service
built by fellow youtubers to escape the
unjust rules of the algorithm all of my
content is hosted over their ad free and
most of my recent videos include special
content that can only be seen on nebula
sign up today by heading over to
curiositystream.comknowingbetter where
you can get access to both
curiositystream and nebula for only
14.79 a year you'll also be supporting
the channel when you do
i'm not going to apologize for the
length of this video or the delay in its
release because you've come to expect
that by now i'd like to give a shout out
to my newest golden fork patrons adam
and specialist angel figueroa if you'd
like to add your name to this list of
debt peons head on over to patreon.com
knowingbetter or for a one-time donation
paypal dot me slash knowingbetter don't
forget to emancipate that subscribe
button or the join button if you're an
abolitionist check out the merch at
knowingbetter.tv follow me on twitter
facebook and instagram and join us on
the subreddit